Gardner clearly expanded the scope of intelligence to include many cognitive
and behavioral abilities. But, with the added domains, means that there isn't a
high correlation between each area of intelligence. So you could be really high
in one area of intelligence, but not so high in another. Greg, do you have
anything to add about Gardner's theory of intelligence?
>> Yeah. Gardner's theory has been very appealing to both educators and
psychologists in the United States and in Europe. But what they've had to do is
develop a whole curricula and schools around multiple intelligences.
>> That's interesting. So it's obviously pretty hard to test this type of
intelligence because that's not a simple pen and paper test like there are for
the traditional IQ tests.
>> That's right. In fact Gardner acknowledges that. He knows that there's no way
of simply taking a pen and paper test to test for interpersonal intelligence
for instance. So what educators have to do in these schools is they have to
have projects and activities, creative activities interpersonal tasks, that
they evaluate.
>> Okay, so let me ask you this. Now, how do you think you are intelligent?
>> Well, I would say I'm pretty high on verbal and interpersonal.
>> Intelligence not so high on musical intelligence.
>> So let me ask you this. How are you intelligent?